ça bienvenue dans la tête d'un couteau
suisse qu'est ce que c'est un peu tôt
sus le couteau si ça a été inventé dans
les années 1880 par l'armée suisse pour
les soldats pour qu'ils puissent aller
sur le front et avoir une lame mais
aussi un ouvre boîte et un poinçon s'il
y avait un souci sur le pistolet pour
voir le réparer non je suis pas là pour
vous parler des couteaux suisses en vrai
je vous parlais des couteaux 6 humain le
couteau suisse humain vous en connaissez
tous
1 c'est cette personne autour de vous ou
vous qui avait plein de projets qui qui
partent toujours dans des idées des fois
vous trouvez farfelues vous en
connaissez des gens comme ça un peu est
ce que vous connaissez les neuro
droitier non alors on va imaginer un
grand cerveau là on va rentrer dans les
neurosciences un petit peu un grand
cerveau donc il ya l'hémisphère gauche
si l hémisphère droit et au milieu le
corps calleux le corps calleux c'est
pour faire les échanges en cent ans
après l'invention du couteau suisse
le docteur spirit découvre que les
suivant l'endroit où se trouve le centre
de raisonnement dans le cerveau il va y
avoir des comportements différents chez
les personnes donc il se rend compte que
70 % de la population à son centre de
raisonnement dans le cerveau gauche
donc c'est les neuro gauche et les neuro
gauche et qu'on peut appeler les
spécialistes
en fait l'organisation de leur cerveau
va faire qu'ils ont un raisonnement
étape par étape et qui vont préférer un
spécialisation devenir expert donc là je
leur présente avec une petite loupe
il va devenir expert d'un sujet quand on
va du côté des neuro droitier donc ici
le couteau suisse
ça représente que 30% de la population
et c'est un raisonnement qui va être
global et intuitif c'est un
fonctionnement qui va faire que ces
personnes vont fonctionner avec
plusieurs projets
en fait pourquoi c'est physiologique le
cerveau d'une heureux droitier il a un
influx nerveux plus rapide du coup il a
des réseaux de neurones qui vont
l'information va tourner plus vite entre
le re les réseaux de neurones et on va
avoir une information qui circule plus
vite ça veut pas dire qu'il y en a un
des deux qui est meilleur que l'autre
en fait en fait ils sont tous les deux
différents c'est physiologique par
exemple pour comparer on peut voir que
vous vous avez l'air assez grand quand
vous allez au cinéma vous avez légende
qui équipent l'isle-adam le siège
non ça désagréable quand vous êtes trop
grand par contre vous pouvez attraper
les gâteaux au delà de l'armoire et si
vous êtes petit va falloir déplacer la
chaise pourra chercher les gâteaux mais
au cinéma
tranquillou bilou on croise les jambes
toi bien différent pas mieux pas moins
bien c'est les différences des nouveaux
chais et des neuro droitier lenovo
droitier leur route non c'est les
personnes multi potentiel et les
personnes sur deux ces deux
fonctionnements ces deux fonctionnements
hyper complémentaires il naquit va aller
au sujet au plus profond du sujet et
l'autre qui va avoir une vision plus
globale qui va pouvoir coordonner un peu
l'ensemble et travailler ensemble
j'ai déjà fait avec des collègues qui
était spécialiste sur du code en
informatique et nos projets et est
toujours incroyable parce qu'on a
vraiment une plus value sur les deux
fonctionnements ensemble seulement
aujourd'hui dans notre société c'est pas
forcément évident en tant que nouveau
droitier de trouver sa voie
on nous encourage quand même vachement
anneaux spécialisés j'ai quand même
essayé j'ai essayé plusieurs pistes
professionnelles
je suis devenu plongeuse en biologie
marine en laboratoire de biologie marine
en australie
je suis devenu ingénieur et chef de
projet dans la viticulture
je suis devenue animatrice en centre
aéré
je suis devenu agent d'entretien je suis
devenu plein de choses j'ai essayé des
choses mais je n'étais pas complète
quand j'essayais ces choses ce que je
voulais une spécialisée dans chacune de
ces choses
du coup je les ai mises derrière et je
me suis dit ces choses là
ces métiers là me plaisait pas parce que
c'était pas mes valeurs j'ai cherché ma
valeur j'ai passé du temps à chercher
m'avait là et je me suis retrouvé à
monter une boîte une association dans le
milieu de l'économie sociale et
circulaires sociale et solidaire c'était
génial
j'ai passé deux ans comment un poisson
dans l'eau avec des collègues qui eux
mêmes avaient des projets incroyables
ont partagé nos valeurs de coopération
de solidarité de respect de
l'environnement d'impact sur la société
et notre environnement
c'était incroyable comme expérience et
là encore j'étais pas complète et je
m'étais trompé je m'étais encore
spécialisée dans quelque chose alors du
coup c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
commencé à fureter et que j'ai découvert
ce neuro droitier qui sait ce nouveau
boîtier du coup en fait au début j ai
pas cru parce que les mots associés
surdoué multi potentiel à l'époque
j'étais encore dans le mouvement de 7
des gens qui sont rapides sont
intelligents là ça me ressemble
non parce que moi en plus j'ai grandi on
va beaucoup répéter savait il faut
souffrir pour être belle
du coup j'étais vraiment dans clair aux
autres c'était clairement pas un bon
choix mais du coup j'ai découvert ça
puis petit à petit bon j'ai fini par m'y
résoudre que peut-être effectivement ça
me correspondait alors alors j'ai
découvert les atouts incroyable des
neuro droitier ils sont pas incroyable
les atouts
un heureux et y est donc le couteau
suisse il est hyper adaptable ça c'est
un peu ce que j'ai fait dans ma vie il
est hyper adaptable et c'est une chance
aujourd'hui avec tous les enjeux qu'on
croise pour la société on est pas
dissipé
on est vraiment adaptable les couteaux
suisses ils ont une capacité
d'apprentissage très rapide qui peut
être très approfondies en très peu de
temps et ça c'est génial ça permet
d'être légitime dans ce qu'on fait même
si on fait beaucoup de choses
différentes et enfin la créativité
le fait d'avoir plusieurs projets
différents va nous permettre d'avoir des
projets des idées inédites qu'on va
sortir
moi j'ai pas très loin de celle ci il ya
aussi les motilité l'hypersensibilité
c'est des caractéristiques des couteaux
suisses
c'est qu'on va dire les choses avec
beaucoup d'intensité forte de tout ça je
me suis regardé je me suis dit bon tout
ça c'est mes qualités maintenant il faut
que je trouve mon équilibre parce que
jusque là je n'ai pas trouvé encore du
coup j'ai cherché j'ai tâtonné les
tester et maintenant j'ai quatre piliers
aujourd'hui j'écris tv les bons ça donne
ça
c'est génial pour moi je peux aller dans
toutes les directions qui m'intéresse je
peux aller apprendre tout ce que je veux
en ce moment je suis gaga d'astronomie
je passe mon temps dans ses bouquins là
je sais pas pourquoi c'est bon
fonctionnement mon deuxième pilier
c'est l'économie sociale et solidaire
j'ai pas pu la quitter je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je dois m'engager dans
cette voie là pour trouver des solutions
pour lui le futur notre futur mon
troisième pilier c'est un boulot
alimentaire puisque faut pas déconner ça
marche pas comme ça qui est très bien et
je suis contente parce que j'arrive à
expliquer maintenant bon fonctionnement
et mes collègues le respecte et enfin
mon dernier pilier et pas des moindres
c'est le repos on a tous besoin de se
reposer et si on veut se connaître et se
connecter faut qu'on se repose
voilà mes quatre piliers et comment je
les trouvais donc en tâtonnant une fois
maintenant que je suis à l'équilibré que
je suis vraiment dans un équilibre où je
me sens épanoui je sais que je pourrais
aller découvrir d'autres choses et je
sais aussi que j'ai c'est debout seul
maintenant qui me permet de tâtonner je
vais dans cette direction ma boussole me
dit oh non ça marche pas en fait c'est
dans mes tripes que je sens ça je me
sens pas très bien
du coup je changeais la boussole là elle
est contente j'y vais et là je sens que
c'est ma bonne direction ça la boussole
c'est l'intuition et bien que ce soit un
raisonnement intuitif pour le couteau
suisse
tout le monde a de l'intuition que ce
soit le spécialiste ou le couteau suisse
du coup je vous recommande vraiment si
vous voulez de suivre votre anti sion de
prendre le petit bout seul à la main là
et de ressentir et quand on ressent on
va vraiment se connaître mieux se
respecter et surtout s'amuser
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]